en bolivia hoy en día se están
debatiendo dos formas de gobierno de
gobernabilidad una en un bajo una mirada
unipolar anclada lo que significa el
partido del ex presidente evo morales en
una perspectiva de que ellos tienen la
posibilidad de otorgarle al país
estabilidad social y gobernabilidad con
su capa con la capacidad de su sola
estructura política y una gobernabilidad
que debe ser negociada compartida en
función de pactos políticos que es la
que podría poder ofrecer el señor carlos
meza bajo la lógica solamente de poder
llevar adelante e implementar un
gobierno con un pacto político
democrático con el señor luís fernando
camacho del departamento de santa cruz
que ocupa el tercer lugar son dos formas
de gobierno y dos miradas de democracia
distintas también